[Music]
obviously any band any group someday is
not going to be together anymore that's
just you know the truth I think anybody
kind of knows that whether you say it or
not
fifth harmony announces Camilla Kibeho
is leaving the group the band revealed
the new Sunday via a statement on social
media writing in part quote after four
and a half years of being together we
have been informed via her
representatives that Camilla has decided
to leave fifth harmony we wish her well
we will be moving forward with the four
of us this is definitely our first love
so there always been the foundation of
everything so no regardless of
everything that's been going on oh it's
always been focused behind me just hours
before announcing Camilla's unexpected
departure from the group all five band
members perform together at Y 100's
Jingle Ball in Sunrise Florida later on
Camilla hit the stage again this time as
a solo artist to sing bad things her
duet with rapper Machine Gun Kelly
I
[Music]
are you shocked to see Camila lead the
group or did you see this one coming
tweet us at ET now
[Music]
you